Speaker 1: We want to hopefully be done with
this question of is the former President Donald
Trump going to be able to hide records, phone
records and other records from the lead up
to and the immediate aftermath of the January
20, January six, 2021, Trump riots?
The Supreme Court is now rejecting Donald
Trump's bid to hide the riot records.
Is this finally going to be the end?
I really hope so.
First of all, remember the context?
This is about riot records being provided
to the January 6th House Committee that is
investigating the Trump riots.
ABC News, CBS News rather reports.
The Supreme Court on Tuesday turned away former
President Donald Trump's legal fight with
the White House, with the House Select Committee
investigating the Jan. six assault on the
U.S. Capitol bringing an end.
We can only hope bringing an end to the former
president's quest to stop investigators from
accessing reams of documents from his final
weeks in the White House.
Trump asked the Supreme Court in December
to take up his appeal of a decision from the
federal appeals court in Washington, D.C.,
which rejected his efforts to shield the documents
from lawmakers and found Trump provided, quote
no basis for it to override President Biden's
decision not to uphold his predecessor's claim
of executive privilege over the records.
In rejecting the former president's request,
the decision from the U.S. Court of Appeals
for the District of Columbia Circuit remains
in place.
In addition to asking the Supreme Court to
review the lower court's decision, Trump requested
the justices stop the transfer of records
from the National Archives to House investigators.
They declined to do so last month, and the
select committee received more than 700 pages
of records sought by the panel earlier this
month.
So is this finally the end?
I really hope so because I am so sick of this.
He was president.
Those are our records.
These are not Trump's documents to control.
These are our records, and they should go
to the committee investigating this.
And of course, you are innocent until proven
guilty.
Trump has not been charged with anything.
He gets an opportunity for all of that stuff.
In a colloquial setting like this, which is
not a court of law, this is just a show.
One would naturally wonder why would you be
so anxious for those records not to become
public?
If you have nothing to hide now, there are
two explanations, and I want to be fair.
One explanation is he has something to hide.
That's a completely reasonable colloquial
explanation we might all come to without saying
that means he is legally guilty of anything.
He just he has stuff to hide.
Fine.
The other one, and it could be this is that
it's a really effective legal strategy.
You always push back and you always obstruct
everything.
Even really simple requests, uncontroversial
requests, even if later it'll be revealed
there was no criminal wrongdoing there or
whatever.
And that makes it harder to figure out when
is Trump really being sketchy and really has
something to hide?
What I mean by that is imagine that there
were ten requests made of Donald Trump and
Trump's really only concerned about one of
those requests, and that's the only one that
he fights.
You're you're telegraphing where investigators
should really be paying attention.
You're signaling where is the wrongdoing really
hidden?
If there are ten requests made and you're
only worried about one of them, but you try
to obstruct all 10, you are making it more
difficult to determine which of these 10 things
should we really be focusing on.
And so I think that that it's completely plausible
that that's just the legal strategy here.
And that's why Donald Trump is doing this
in terms of Trump's willingness to put records
out there.
Remember that he was just about to publish
those tax returns back in 2015 and then 2016
as soon as the IRS audit was done.
And we never got those tax tax records.
So we know he never has any intention of publishing
anything.
Last thought, imagine being an adult.
And seeing Trump's behavior forget about during
his presidency, but just over the last year
since he's been out of office and still being
impressed with him and thinking that he's
an alpha and thinking that he's smart and
a good businessperson and a good decision
maker, it says almost more about the people
that still support the guy than it does about
Trump himself.
Send me your thoughts.
You can find us on Facebook at facebook.com
The David Pakman Show.
After this break, we're going to hear from
Merrick Garland and much more.